[Music]
on this saturday night
breaking news and bad news for the
toronto blue jays
ottawa says no to their plan for home
games
what a strikeout means for canada's
major league baseball team
indoor bars open in parts of ontario but
doctors say
drinking and distancing don't mix well
remembering a civil rights icon when you
see something that is not right
not just not fair you have a moral
obligation to say
something from selma alabama to black
lives matter
how john lewis inspired a generation
plus it was like a contract you've
actually signed something that says you
can't sell to non-white
reckoning with a racist legacy in real
estate
and the stormy start to summer for
weather weary albertans
[Music]
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight
our nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us well canada's major league baseball
team the toronto blue jays was hit
hard today the federal government
rejected a pitch for the jays to play at
home
in the midst of kovat 19 despite a
proposed baseball bubble to keep players
safe
the strikeout according to ottawa is
based on the advice of public health
officials
let's bring in our erica bella
now earlier available week we saw
officials at both the city and
provincial level supporting
the idea of having the team play at the
rogers center now right now
anyone entering canada for non-essential
reasons is required to self-isolate for
14 days
and major league baseball needed an
exemption to this rule
for the team to play here now the jays
are
in toronto for training camp but when
the season begins next week
both the jays and their opponents would
be traveling back and forth between
canada and the u.s where transmission
remains high
and i understand that that professional
sports are very important i'm a lifelong
jazz fan i was born in toronto
i was at the sky dome as it was then
known in 1992 when we first won
i remember uh the bad flip by uh jose
bautista
these are really really important
milestones but but they can't drive
uh important decisions when it comes to
our border and when it comes to the
health
and safety of canadians we have to look
at the evidence we have to look at the
advice that we're getting
now the blue jays president and ceo says
he supports or he
takes on the federal government's
decision
and at this point he says he's now
focused
on looking towards the future and his
focus is finding
a home field for the 2020 season
dan eden is the only one that is a
hundred percent seamless right now and
ready to go
um that from a player health standpoint
has some challenges
uh buffalo is certainly one that we
spent a lot increasing amount of time in
the past few weeks
but we continue to that is not done and
there are
some infrastructure and player facility
challenges that we would have to address
to get that up to major league standards
the federal government rejecting the
plan even though the provincial
government
was comfortable with it now erica the
ontario government is being criticized
for part of its
phase three rollout as well
that's right farah this is the first
weekend gyms
restaurants and bars are buzzing as
large portions of ontario
enter into phase three but the
association representing
doctors in the province is urging the
government
to rethink part of that plan i came here
i got here at about 5 45
i jumped out i'm ready to go first in
line for his first
workout at this gym in peterborough
ontario
it's something he's waited for for four
months it's been a long wait
so hopefully all the gyms throughout the
gta start opening up
for now ontario is taking a regional
approach and reopening
only certain parts of the province have
been given the green light to move on to
stage three
and that doesn't include toronto it
means larger gatherings are now
permitted
a maximum of 50 people went indoors and
a hundred people went outdoors
restaurants can go back to serving
people inside
it was very exciting on friday this
restaurant in waterloo
opened its dining room to the public the
chance to kind of
have people inside again have more
tables and have that opportunity again
was really really positive on the same
day
the ontario medical association issued
an open letter to the provincial
government
warning of the risks of reopening bars
we've seen an
incident and an uptick in the incidents
as soon as bars open and we've seen
outbreaks local outbreaks associated
with bars
this after at least 45 kovic 19 cases
were linked to several bars in montreal
and so we're saying that we're not sure
the benefit
of opening bars outweighs the risks just
yet
this restaurant manager says he
understands the concern
he says staff are working to keep guests
safe that becomes our job to make sure
that
there's enough people in there to to
police those
policies and again you know
we do have to lean a little bit on our
guests to say this
this is for your safety at kentucky
bourbon and barbecue
even with the ability to dine indoors at
the end of the day it is still patio
season
you know people i think generally still
prefer to sit outside but glasgow says
having the ability
to offer indoor dining for the summer
allows staff to prepare for the fall
when patio season does end so we can
kind of use it as like a
pilot situation right now to make sure
that we have all these measures in place
erica vela global news toronto
another developing story tonight there
are reports multiple people are injured
and there are possible casualties
after a bus rollover in alberta between
jasper and banff national parks
the rollover happened late today in an
area of the columbia ice fields on
highway 93
a popular place for tourists three
helicopters have been dispatched to the
scene as the emergency
unfolds police are asking people to
avoid the area
so many canadians are on the move this
weekend trying to make the most of
summer
but there are concerns complacency could
cause an
uptick of covet 19. there are more than
109
000 cases in canada and from east to
west
provinces are warning everyone to stay
safe
in quebec today what just began a
two-week construction holiday
people over 12 years old must now wear
face masks
inside public places the federal
government says it is ordering more than
75 million
syringes alcohol swabs and bandages
to help treat canadians as soon as a
vaccine
is approved in india
where coronavirus cases have passed one
million
three generations of bollywood's most
famous family are in hospital
with covet 19. ashwarya rai bachchan and
her eight-year-old daughter have been
admitted to mumbai's top
private hospital her husband and iconic
father-in-law amitabh bachchan
were hospitalized earlier this week the
46-year-old actress had been isolating
at home since testing positive
on sunday people around the world paused
today to remember
south africa's first black president
nelson mandela and his legacy fighting
for equal rights
but as the world marked mandela day
south africa still suffers
inequality like a collapsing public
health system
tonight there are fears kovat 19 will
make the situation in south africa
even worse we're already 350
000 people have been infected health
officials say the country
is on a similar pandemic path as the u.s
brazil india and russia and could soon
become one of the hardest hit countries
and on the day nelson mandela is
remembered for his fearless advocacy
the world mourns an american civil
rights hero
who helped change history longtime
georgia congressman
john lewis lost his battle with cancer
at the age of 80.
lewis served for 33 years in congress
and was fighting for equal rights
long before that jennifer johnson
reports on his legacy
and guiding light for future generations
congressman john lewis was a man of
dedication a champion for his country
and the fight for civil rights
the son of alabama sharecroppers lewis
believed peaceful protests could change
history
we can change america and in changing
america we can change the world
arrested more than 40 times often beaten
lewis was one of the leaders of the
non-violent protest movement against
laws in the south
that segregated white and black
americans in schools buses
even drinking fountains in 1963 lewis
was the youngest speaker at the march on
washington
but it was this 1965 march that started
in selma alabama
heading to montgomery the state's
capital that made louis famous
when we were marching across that bridge
just simple saying
people wanted to register to vote they
got as far as the edmund pettus bridge
in selma turned around and dispersed
and they came toward us beating us with
nightsticks
using tear gas and tramping up their
horses
that day is known as bloody sunday lewis
was left with a fractured skull
the images of police brutality ignited a
nation
five months later president lyndon
johnson signed the voting rights act
into law i'm john lewis
for congress lewis kept fighting against
racial injustice in washington
elected in 1986 he became one of the
country's leading liberal democrats
never backing down from a fight from
health care to gun control to the
impeachment of u.s president donald
trump
when you see something that is not right
not
just not fair you have a moral
obligation to set something
to do something despite battles between
lewis and the president
flags have been lowered to half-mast at
the white house tributes have poured in
from former presidents
and current politicians as americans
mourn this loss
in 2011 president barack obama awarded
lewis the presidential medal
of freedom america's highest civilian
honor
when parents teach their children what
is meant by courage
the story of john lewis will come to
mind lewis became a published author
and won the national book award in 2016.
an emotional
tribute for a man denied a library card
as a child
we were told that the libraries were
whites only not for colors
and to come here and receive this award
dishonored with this it's too much
just weeks before his death lewis
summoned the strain to visit the black
lives matter plaza in washington
he was surrounded by activists in awe of
his courage and strength
it was very moving five years ago almost
to the day lewis tweeted one of his mug
shots with a caption
even though i was arrested i smiled
because i was on the right side of
history
find a way to get in the way jennifer
johnson global news
washington calls for racial justice and
an end to systemic racism remains strong
in the aftermath of george floyd's
killing
today demonstrators in toronto rallied
to defund the city's police service
and took aim at some historic monuments
[Applause]
three people were arrested after
protesters tossed paint on statues of
canada's first prime minister
sir john a macdonald a statue of king
edward vii
outside the ontario legislature and on
the monument to egerton ryerson on the
ryerson university campus
members of the toronto chapter of black
lives matter
said the statues perpetuate the history
of colonialism
and anti-black violence oregon's
governor says president donald trump's
deployment to federal agents
patrolling the streets of portland and
arresting protesters
is a blatant abuse of power
the unidentified and camouflaged clad
authorities
have been seen over several nights
rounding up protesters
and taking them away in unmarked
vehicles the trump administration
ordered the troops to protect federal
buildings
where demonstrators have been rallying
for more than 50 nights
the u.s attorney for oregon is calling
for an investigation
saying the use of militarized forces on
the city streets
is reflective of tactics of a dictator
coming up on global national 5g for
freedom
i asked canada's foreign affairs
minister whether the release of the two
michaels
could be leveraged with a huawei deal
this week britain became the latest
western nation to
formally restrict the chinese telecom
giant huawei from its
5g network which means canada is now
the only nation in the so-called five
eyes intelligence sharing alliance
to not have some kind of formal ban or
restriction
on huawei this comes as we near 600 days
of imprisonment for two canadians in
china
ottawa says michael spevor and michael
kufrick
are being arbitrarily held as pawns in
retaliation for the arrest
of huawei chief financial officer mong
won joe
on a u.s extradition request in an
interview airing sunday on the west
block
i asked canada's foreign minister
francois philippe champine
whether he thinks the decision on
whether to allow huawei to operate in
canada
could be used as a bargaining chip to
secure the freedom of the two michaels
he insists that's simply not the case
i would not make any link with the two
issues one is to ensure the security of
our network
and our national security in general i
think canadians want us to
to make uh the right decision to be
thoughtful in our analysis to consult
with
intelligence agency uh to make sure we
protect
uh our our system our communication
system for now and for decades to come
i would not make any link between the
two i'll also ask the foreign minister
about recent reports that russian
hackers may be trying to steal sensitive
information
about coronavirus vaccine trials here
plus with september just around the
corner many parents are concerned about
what school is going to look like
in the fall what are other countries
doing and are we behind
i'll speak with two leading voices on
how to safely reopen schools
that's all coming up tomorrow on the
west block when i'll be sitting in for
mercedes stevenson
null and void but not forgotten
next why one bc politician is digging up
real estate's racist past
flames burst from this cathedral in
france for hours in the western city of
nantes
it took over 100 firefighters to control
the blaze which
blew stained glass windows and destroyed
the grand organ
officials suspect arson and say three
fires had been started at the 15th
century site
a politician in british columbia is
calling on his municipality
to erase a racist covenant that prevents
people from selling their homes to
non-white
buyers it was a shocking discovery for
marcus wong
when he bought his house in west
vancouver and as robin gill reports
there are other
neighborhoods in canada that until
recently
had the same racism when it comes to
real estate
the british properties is a posh
neighborhood in west vancouver a
suburb of vancouver this is where marcus
wong grew up
well i certainly remember the times when
you know going around the community
people reminding me sort of subtly like
you know like this is why the british
properties are called the british
properties
van wong bought a house and there it was
in writing
why he felt so unwelcome the covenant in
the land title that says
no person of the african or asiatic race
or
african or asiatic descent except
servants
of the occupier of the premises in
residence shall reside or be allowed to
remain
on the premises the language is very
striking it's very shocking in fact
wong is now a counselor for west
vancouver and has introduced a motion
to have this redacted even though it is
technically null and void in canada
this part of the country isn't the only
neighborhood with real estate rules that
promote
racial segregation in 1920
an equally troubling covenant was
enacted in the neighborhood of victoria
park
now part of calgary's stampede grounds
residents who lived in the broadview and
o'connor area of toronto
weren't allowed to sell to jews or
persons of objectionable nationality
it was deemed illegal in 1945 and it
wasn't
until 2019 that the same anti-semitic
sentiment was removed from the books
in the city of san juan so richelieu
near montreal
it was like a contract you've actually
signed something that says you can't
sell to non-white
if you do someone can actually take you
to court and the courts
will find against you and they did
historian henry yu has studied racism in
real estate as far back as the beginning
of colonialism in canada
but he doesn't think these covenants
should actually be erased
since they're already null and void i
would really be opposed
to everybody quietly changing their
legal titles
and you know getting them updated and
making it seem like that history didn't
occur wong is steadfast in his resolve
to have the covenant erased in the place
where he was born
but believes it will serve as a history
lesson really
have that frank discussion of who do we
want to be as canadians you know
how does this match up or doesn't match
up with our values as a nation
west vancouver council votes on this
motion in the fall
and while there may not be blatant
outrage there is certainly an
uncomfortable feeling to know that this
rule
is still on the books robin gill global
news west vancouver
cruel summer canada's costliest
hailstorm hits the province
while it's down
even before the pandemic's financial
blow alberta was poised to suffer
its worst ever economic decline
and the largest in canada now the
province's money woes have been worsened
by mother nature
the costliest hail storm in canadian
history has left alberta
in shambles this summer and as jenna
freeman reports
experts chalk it up to bad luck
in june vinyl sightings stripped from
homes
shattered windshields in northeast
calgary the cost
catastrophic at 1.2 billion dollars it's
the costliest hail storm in canadian
history
then july in minutes crops cut in half
more hail hammering the province of
alberta well this was a field of wheat
that was up to my waist
these photos were taken 24 hours apart a
storm near innisfail leveling dwayne
bennett's craw
massive wind and over six inches of hail
and we've lost 14 out of 1600 acres
probably
enter the hail suppression team taking
to the skies to try and mitigate some of
the damage from mother nature
implemented in 1996 the planes used
technology to produce ice crystals
intended to reduce the size of hail and
in turn the damage caused by it
so far this summer the teen hasn't
tracked the number of storms going up
but says that the damage that's being
incurred is
increasingly severe our high statistics
for severe storms and operations
it's increased the conditions seem to be
more
severe within the last 10 years
and expensive few decades ago insurers
were paying out on average 500 million
dollars a year
that number has almost quadrupled to
almost 1.9 billion dollars a year
this year alberta insurers alone are
expected to dole out two billion dollars
according to environment canada the
record-setting hail storm that hit
calgary
can simply be chalked up to bad luck
those storms usually happen
just in the foothills not over top a
city researchers still don't know why
storms are more destructive
those details will come with additional
data and analysis
but with at least half of storm season
still left
it becomes an anxious game of waiting
and watching
jenna freeman global news calgary
and that's global national for this
saturday i'm farah nasser tonight's your
canada
is the toronto skyline does your
community have a unique landmark you'd
like to share with us
email your pictures to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks so much for watching until
tomorrow take care of yourselves
and each other good night